welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm joined by Tom Koch Hill who is one
of the founders of logical resources
FMCG who are a specialist FMCG
recruitment business good afternoon
based in Leeds my chilis to set the
scene we're in it's a unique office very
I call it the time machine because it's
like nineteen seventies the consi we're
in the room we're in front of us we've
got sort of something sort of graffiti
which is that the lead foot will ground
yes it's basically leads you've got our
office on there with a little window
that's oh you've got you've got Allen
Road you've got the the arena Town Hall
and some of the other of the major
buildings one of the guys and the office
is like just does I know we left the
prison I'm surprised yes or in a
co-working room yeah really cool office
cool building first time in Leeds
welcome and for those that may or may
not of listened or know but me and Tom
Anton business partner Sam sat down
which seems like an absolute lifetime
ago back when I was a office look so
media and we was in the studio there it
was a very very very very hot day oh
never did that video do I know we were
sweating so and Tom and Sam came down to
record some video content and yeah it
just happened to be like just a crazy
hot day and those fans have to be used
you had to be high because we are oh my
god is crazy and so yeah so I think
obviously we've sat down before Tom so
people may have some context but I guess
why don't we just start by why don't you
just show everyone sort of way way right
now as a business what you specialize in
and just make that crystal clear and
then we'll just sort of break down and
talk about sort of the journey up until
now cool so we're accrue within consumer
so I was say if you're going to ask
there anything you can buy on the
shelves in Ulster we recruit for the
companies that make and supply those
products basically so the big names are
Mars Unilever coca-cola
perhaps I'm on set we recruit for all of
those but those are the sort you big
brands right through to Green Corps and
crumbs we can make all the sandwiches
you might buy the food to go counter we
predominantly where we grew up
recruiting their national account
managers and marketing people however in
the last two years we've expanded that's
where you look after supply chain we can
do technical sort of new product
development can do engineering and
operations and production and we also a
looking at going into heavily going into
e-commerce that's I think that's going
to be the next big step on the Rosi
effort so companies like that right
because you're he's just the next
logical step really I said he's just
it's it's where obviously where the
revenues attention is is there's a lot
of jobs in it it fits nicely go see all
these ecommerce companies they're still
selling consumer products it's just
another route to markets we need to get
we're learning about the moment I try to
understand where we could fit in and
what what we could provide for these
companies with that you know the big
boys aren't doing a sauce tends to be
our strategies to start the business
with sound yeah obviously who you met in
your recruitment days right yes some
used to work for me I was his boss oh
yeah so start the business Sam what's
that how many years ago now five years
last week five years last week yeah Wow
yeah I know it's crazy isn't it five
years and obviously way so where you are
now as a business in terms of how many
people you have now in the business 25
full-time and then we we use people on
an ad-hoc basis that we need basically
yeah yeah we need them but yeah so it's
twenty-five
split up we've just hired an ops manager
I think that's like our that was just
sort of realizing we're like a grown-up
business now that we actually yeah that
we can't do it you hear a lot from
people where especially start with
another person knowing each other's
strengths like are you someone who's
good at the operations or is it more so
it was a good really but it all got put
on my shoulders really literally the
world's worst administrator so I'm not
very organized so when did you as a
person
about two months ago how's it being
brilliant absolutely fantastic yeah yeah
is just everything will get his goal is
to move into sort of a finance and
operations leadership position in the
company so he's got lots of ops
experience within recruitment so he
knows he knows our recruitment company
from the internal aspects but for his
development we're gonna put him through
all his accountancy exams and we're
gonna were gonna support him on that and
we've known him for a long time it's a
good mate of our head of marketing so
also for me it was about bringing
somebody in who can who can grow with
the business yeah and I'd rather
somebody who not bringing some you know
super expensive finance director in
which we don't really need this I want
somebody who can really understand the
financial side of the businesses again
I'm not an accountant either Sam were a
cruise that's what we're good at
so what what what we're trying to do is
just outsource all the jobs that we've
been doing that we're not nice I don't
really show a real good app yeah
yes and we can continue recruiting so
timeline I think wait so when we last
sat down which is like 18 months ago two
years ago where is your head count wise
I think we're at four people I think it
was me Sam
Aidan Faridah maybe Connor yeah I'm not
sure if Connor was with us then so
that's like somewhat significant we came
to see you because we wanted to hire
people and you were filming our ayran
videos yes it was really early days from
I mean so like there's been some
significant growth yeah over the last
turn abit years yes and Howard just
quickly just for everyone because like I
don't always like to because I think
it's come up quite a lot where I'll see
in just today's world headcount can
easily be the thing that you talk about
that doesn't necessarily mean your
business is more profitable anything
right so and like let's get to it was
you more a lot obviously four or five
people
profits taken a hit right profit per
head was high obviously we make more
money now yeah but the percentage is
lower but you know we haven't got we
haven't got investors we've gotten you
know means some of the only shareholders
throws it's you know we own a nice
living now we've got enough money I know
it's not about that for me anymore so
and it's really never has been I'm not
I'm not massively money motivated
past the point I need enough to live off
and I like some nice things I like these
and holidays but some easy to park
growing it so this year come vs. last
year's probably the biggest difference
so we made a lot of money last year and
instead of taking it all we've thought
right we're gonna put it all back in
we're gonna hire hire a lot of people so
think you know sort of some from April
onwards I think we've added probably
like seven people hmm
and they're all betting in and some of
them aren't but some of them are feared
so they're quite those three people who
that we've hired this year who don't
earn fees you know that that's that
they're administrators of the market
saying so that you know they're always
going to be a cost and the other people
have hired he takes time so you know
they're doing okay but you've got to
give them time to bed in so our profit
has gone down this year there's a
percentage but again we're making more
money because all the guys we hired the
year before and now at that place where
they're actually paid targeting rather
because they've had their year to bed in
learn the job yeah build their customer
base network and everything else so
they're now making money and I think
that's how it's always gonna be so why
did you why did you decide why didn't he
did why didn't you and Sam who's decided
to keep it a small business and we
always we always thought that's what it
would be because we just didn't know
what we were capable of and what we
really wanted we both what someone had
to set the business obviously super
ambitious and he's not very good at
taking orders
you know he's his own man and he's you
know he just wanted to get on with it
and thought he could do it better than
everybody else on his own and then he
can so it's a fair play to him mine was
completely free mine was more of a
wildlife balance thing yeah my wife got
pregnant they wouldn't give me any
flexibility at work so I just resigned
so and thought you know my only option
is is to work for myself plus I'm not a
great employee they look at tend to just
do again whatever I like so I was always
destined nothing to the air my own boss
casabas I'm just not very good at things
I'm sold but why didn't I so went when
you when you had a really good year last
year why didn't why didn't you and Sam
go out buy the nice cars how do you
bought a nice house I have just bought a
house Bay again my wife's quite
successful so why did you pull it back
into the business because we after year
two we kind of made that decision that
yeah
grow this we yeah we were like what you
are like this we can do this you know
we've got we've got the capability and
we really enjoying it yeah and we're
gonna build but we're not going to just
do the old typical recruitment thing of
high temp people hope to work out yeah
take our time we're gonna you know
invest in our staff when it's gonna try
build a decent business yeah it doesn't
have to be the biggest it's not to be
the most profitable just a decent solid
business that delivers for its customers
and creates opportunities for its
employees so that is basically our
mission those are those two principles
deliver for our customers and create
opportunities for our employees that I
that's what drives this company those
those two things everything else you do
those two things everything takes care
of itself you know that the beginning no
we said the beginning that was just like
how can I make an income to cover my my
personal cost whenever some people I
speak to people about bit further down
the line and then terms of having real
cream and business or think about
starting there obviously it's like how
much of a plan do I need and something
that came conversation recently was yeah
plans gray but that can change I think
the most important thing is purpose and
like no more that is a no no we don't
plan we yeah we were doing it now we
don't because you know what we're now at
the point where we can't carry everybody
yeah I mean you said carry you mean in
terms of you and Sam being yes if
biggest Fiona's yes we can't cover
everybody's Billings anymore and grow
the business that way so and to be fair
we you know we've got a good solid core
of consistent billers next yeah and
we're adding to that more training those
people up and bringing yourself into to
help train our future leaders our
management team that'll hopefully gonna
build their own teams under them so we
cuss and we've got to get a bit more a
bit more strategic a bit more grown-up a
bit more sort of commercial about how we
run the business to make sure that we
don't like [ __ ] it all base yeah and and
we've you know we've got people relying
yeah I had when I sat down a guy Chuck
called Tim he scouted his business over
I think a four year period from him
working from home
- yeah now sort of 2030 people when he
said a big part of that is is that you
got implement processes when before
didn't have processes I'm quite
processed rivets that's never been a
problem for really I'll like them yeah I
like a process I like to understand how
something works yeah so I do like that
sums a bit more playboy make happen yeah
he's awesome but just make it happen so
said that the bringing in JAXA to run
our operations has been really good cuz
I mean the guy is literally like the
most organized near in the world he's
got loads of good ideas and he's a good
communicator so he's getting he's
implementing a lot of processes so he's
taking a lot of work off my desk
hmm so all the finance or the accounts
or the billing you know credit control
you know just even things like kitchen
roaches everything you know just all the
small stuff that just takes up your time
so he's taking all that away so I can
focus on managing how difficult was that
to let go those stuff no not a problem
but happy to delegate was there a
challenge was there a challenge in like
actually understanding what to delegate
or not no goose up I'm quite simple I
want to be a recruiter yeah so I
appreciate you know you've got the
director title of running the company
and you know I spend a lot of time on
that and as we get bigger out I know
that will take up more time but somes
really good at that piece so I like
recruiting I like feeling job so I bring
I like developing customers and bringing
them in and and grow in that that the
business that we do with them so that's
why that's what I love to do so I yeah
the more I can do that create a time for
me to do that
that thus you know it's gonna make me
happy as we get bigger I appreciate that
I'm gonna have to do less and less of
that yeah and run the company which
again is a challenge because I think
I'll just always just do business
development really just wanna say I love
being now I like selling
I like getting to know people yeah
fascinated by all these companies work
yeah it's good about them what they need
to improve I love going on a factory
visit see know a production line works I
just love it all you know it's what I've
done for only ever done recruitment just
wandering for 15 years now and I'm I'm
really I'm passionate about it but
there's gonna become a time where I
probably don't do any recruitment
anymore bunch I'm clinging on you sweat
if I'm listening right now I'm thinking
no
sort of delegating all those sort of
things that Tom listed there that sounds
like a really good idea but like Wendy
when would be I don't know if wish you
did that made out her earlier
no he's when you guys for me Sophie's
because that's a cost center now so
there's no profit yeah I mean your
savers money Jack's already saved just a
couple of money quite a bit of money on
certain things but it's I call them I've
always said to certain jobs that core
hires and then you've got luxury hires
ok Jack's my foot our first look sure we
hire so cuz everybody else is like you
can't run the business without them yeah
but then for me this hire is that you
can ruin the business without them but
if you hire them they're gonna make the
business better I think you've got to
get to a certain point
what's that fine what what was the point
you just taste a profit level for me you
know can we afford to pay salaries you
know and and you know can we give him an
opportunity to develop in the business
so if I'm just bringing him in on what
he's on and it's right you're gonna be
doing the exact same job for the next
ten years he stopped going to stay very
long is it I've got to create an
opportunity for him to the hence the
there holds getting moved to the board
with the finest art so that's his plan
in Philly and that's you know that's why
he's working towards and it's the same
with everybody don't hire anybody unless
I can you know just give them a
progression plan it's like you do this
this and this everybody else to choose
what they need to achieve we can create
these opportunities for you and that's
that's how we do it not some I like that
I'm really enjoy doing them no I just
think that's interesting because I think
especially as you're going through that
journey of four or five heads ten heads
more it's difficult now I feel like I
feel like there's someone dedicated to
those types of tasks and
responsibilities will enable the people
listening to spend more time and what
they need to
yeah I'd say was it was quite easy up to
fifteen was that we didn't struggle it
was it was all natural without was easy
day just just running the command in the
row in the business and we're really
lucky that what five years in I think
we've had five people leave in the whole
time we've been working one one's gone
to another recruit the rest of just left
recruitment just it just wasn't for them
for whatever reason so north of 15 was
was well to to fifteen was was fairly
straightforward I could save somebody
had a bad month the core billers had
enough money to cover them you know
enough wanted to
in any any sort of people who had Paul
starts or you know took him a bit longer
to get up to speed now for 15 to 25
we're now at the point where it's it's a
lot more difficult to so it's a lot more
time-consuming there's a lot more work
you have to do outside of just filling
jobs yeah there's a lot more there's a
lot more cost implications you know our
costs are costs have gone up massively
yeah so those are things you've got to
consider and he's just growing things
you've just got a you know you've got to
put it on scram pens you just got to
push forward basically and how do you
how do you ensure you better do a point
now of having some really good people
around you and stuff like that your
employers how how important is it for
for you to communicate what's going on
and why you're getting more people in
and these starts things how have you
gone about that yes so we've been quite
transparent with everything really yeah
I mean my sense that I've been in the
office yeah most of the people I remain
prepared for a so Evans apart from
nothing 3 everybody's come through
internal referral mm-hmm that we've
hired so that helps because that helped
because everybody kind of feels like
they know each other yeah yeah so that
that really helps and because we've all
been together so long and not many
people leave were quite tight-knit so
there's a lot trust there yeah we do we
we submit in terms of just are things
that we do we have we have a monthly one
a monthly Town Hall hmm and I hate the
flame Town Hall but it's just it's
actually a really good way of describing
what it is we're basically samurai I'll
present the month figures what we've
done highlights Employee of the Month we
have a values award every month for
who's like just you know like be more
like them the values out of the park and
all that sort of good stuff and then
based on me in some leave and they do a
town hall which one of the this their
future leaders will run and they
basically have a range of topics every
month that they'll discuss as a team and
feed and then the management the
leadership future leaders will feed that
back to us and then it's up to us to
implement the changes that their
suggestion if you know and its advisory
you know we're not you would not become
do everything but we leave simply
because
you know as much again with him under
there is still a hierarchy there isn't
there and people aren't gonna be as
honest as they could be if were sat in
the room like bei in them so yeah yes
and we leave guv a point somewhere or
something and you know some of the
things that will come off the back of
that then there have been interested in
or been really impactful so yes so this
it's quite a few things that we've
changed so we were doing a lot of
incentives a lot of like small
incentives and then one big one so we
changed that because the smallness and
it's worked really enough to motivate
people nobody really I had about using
that
yeah we're just loving it was cash has
some cash
so we've split that house we said this
year we've done two and to be incentives
basically yeah
one was a scheme which we're going next
week and the other one it's like a
summer trip somewhere but we always let
the team decide where that well we're
going so last year went so ether which
was more yes so so breather before it
was an ayah good yeah it was an
eye-opener it was good fun I did I did I
did two days and then flew out flew home
and the rest day three so yeah I'm too
old for that but yeah so that was good I
don't know what we'll do this year so
what would warmer what where did that
come from do people say that they don't
think the insensitive that gray or yeah
basically just that we had too many yeah
a lot of the time we was all a bit
jumbled up yeah you know there was there
wasn't a process a consistency to the
incentives a lot of them were just ad
hoc yeah yeah so we're trying to get
we're currently doing it now and to be
honest it tomorrow's Town Hall is the
big thorny is about next year's
incentives got an idea
finishes in two months yeah so it's
about next year's incentives I'm
planning for that another thing was
about sort personal development plans I
mean okay so the feedback was that we
weren't focusing on that enough on
individual will really focused on team I
think we're really good collective
movement and and collective development
rather than individuals so we need we we
might have with the back of a town hall
yeah basically just a feedback forum
yeah just just speaking to the team and
understanding more about what they need
as individuals so yeah so that that's
more so again we're planning that now or
some of the topics in tomorrow's things
like dress code because we don't have
one and it's been abused really
literally people turn up in
dressing-gowns and slippers so yeah yeah
so there's a loom a think and I just
think it's about bringing your best self
to work and yeah I don't I don't if
you're rolling out of bed yeah basically
you know joggers and coming to work yes
I just don't think you in the right
frame yeah what I don't want to do is
impose Mike yeah the way I see it's just
it's just like someone you recognize and
you're just bringing it up yes I'll let
them decide yeah they're not that that's
an interesting part right yeah I just
happen to set the company up so what I
don't I'm not I don't taste you know
you're berating so it's gotta be and how
long how long have you been doing these
sort of town since Christmas so oh
really
so one last just before it's just before
Chris 2018 Christmas no no says
literally last year said last December
oh wow I've always done the month end
and we've always had a bit of feedback
but it has formalized it now and I've
removed me and Sam and you come that
that was from a letter was that learning
then yeah I just think we were just
weren't getting the feeb oh I don't
think I just didn't think we were
getting on his feet I think we will
bring to PC and worrying a bit too much
you never say your feelings yes and so
yes so it's all they know that you know
when Sebenza running it this month when
Ben comes towards with the feedback it's
not like who said that yeah there'll be
none of that it's just be like right so
this is what you know Jaron will vote on
things and you know I'm allowing them to
do it because I just think it's I guess
a we're a team so you've got to move too
forward and then with my job as the
leader is just to implement the change
it can drive more impact though if and
things can change if it's coming from
them right and they're arriving there
and it's like I'm happy people are so
much more likely to do things if they
think it's their idea yeah exactly so
you know let them come up with the ideas
and you know if if we think that if we
think they will really work and we can
make them work and we can afford to make
them work if there's a you know cost
behind them
you know the much more loyal it's a
really take hold of it if it's their
idea so that's that's the thing about
the beginning now or that just came
quite naturally to light was you're
quite comfortable we're just like I'm
not a control freak in any way
I'm good at delegating so the less
decisions I have to make
yeah the better for me basically it's a
farm listen right now and I'm like right
this sounds like a good idea I must on a
smaller business like right now it's
probably yet like you said bit jumbled
maybe even the monthly meetings a bit
jumbled and stuff like that what would
you suggest would be a really it's just
from over the last couple of months of
stuff that you've recognized there's
other things that I'm not a good
presenter I'm not very good at
presenting I'm great talking but yeah
we're structure and he's gonna have to
screen out a look at and talk about just
no good so I don't do that I don't do
the presentation sums as a presentation
firstly no actually detail
yeah it's communicating and then they
you hired all your staff Riya so if you
don't rate them enough to help you make
decisions you shouldn't have hired them
in the first place you know why are you
hiring these people if you don't rate
them if you should hire people that you
trust to give you advice and to imp and
to have an impact in your business other
than just the small little narrow job
you've hired them to do don't hire them
further for the business especially in
small businesses with low literacy sat
in a room to stare at each other all day
you know it's not like you know I'm on a
top floor and I don't see anybody with
you know we're all really I said
nobody's got the same experience yeah so
no if you're good present huh yeah just
I don't know what you good and just and
be honest and just be humble about what
you bought you put your craft up
basically and then my list is very long
I'm not a great man manager I'm not a
great direct manager and I'm not into
the detail at all so I you know bring
people in to do that for me yeah so I
guess I guess if you're not if you're
not having a some sort of monthly
communication with your business for a
smaller business I think definitely
started oh if you could even you could
even apply it to your team within the
business right yeah I mean if you even
if you're working for a haze or Michael
Page and you know I'm sure they'll have
office yeah monthly meetings but yeah if
you know if you're leading and managing
it's him for people or you know whatever
size it might be how are you good you
know those but you need to feedback to
them every month how they're doing and
they need to be able to feedback to you
how you all do it and there's no better
way to do that than either you know you
go for lunch once a month or year and a
screen and you do a presentation
yeah and it's trying feeling business I
was in
when was it ran the sort of twelve
people mark like again it yeah it wasn't
there wasn't much structure not that we
needed like the perfect structure but I
think it would have been really good to
sort of have a monthly sort of barometer
of like guys who did this great this
month or maybe we should think about
this or whatever because I think that's
a great thing about working in a smaller
business I think that if I worked in
your business have direct access to you
so if I was really passionate I had a
really strong opinion about feedback
around certain something then that's I
have the possibility to change that yeah
so and I think that's a great that's
such a valuable thing to have hundreds a
lot more people need to maximize that
yeah okay especially small business
that's what I mean you know check your
ego my if you think you saw some sauce
CEO when you've got ten staff it's good
on LinkedIn there but more yeah see each
CEOs and all this sort stuff I'm reminds
founder cringe proud of founding a
company you know view you speak to
anybody who knew me before I said this
business so I am legit
Oh last guy now they would have thought
you know I'm not that guy I'm not I
shouldn't be doing this job by all
accounts I mean I shouldn't I should
have failed you know I'm not I'm not the
person on the top of anybody's list it's
who have done this and I couldn't done
it without some you know and some kind
of hopefully I'd like to think he can
connect that I do think there's a
compliment there mmm-hmm but we you know
we've got to where we are but by no way
we've not made it by any by any means we
literally step one of the ladder but you
know I think we're going in the right
direction but yeah just I think the
problem with a lot of it especially in
this EGH in this industry is there you
go there's just so many big egos I've
worked with so many big egos and it's
almost like the tile matters so more
than anything done they've got this
great tile and I've got ten staff and
it's like yeah it's like they don't look
they don't see the responsibility
they've got that's what I dust my
biggest pressure that's what I worry
about a night is like I've got to pay
wages attendance she owed I mean that's
you know that's that's the worry I've
got a pay raise wages I've got up you
know pay these bills and you know that's
what you're worried about and evening it
goes from I really hope that guy takes
that job that you had when you were a
consultant I've still got like I still
fill a large ops but now I've got
however you'd out however you got better
at dealing with that I don't know I have
my best every year last year really yeah
my biggest ever bill involvements I was
still not impressed I was like 195 okay
so yes I've dad never broke 200 really
it was it was like for me that's less
legit that's like yeah awesome I've
never been a massive biller I give away
a lot so yeah I'm good at getting the
Klein on yeah good opening the door yeah
but yeah I'm a little bit Lucas I'm a
bit haphazard I'm not great at the whole
process even though I've written the
process but yeah no never part you're
good at yes oh yes and now so I don't do
a huge amount of resourcing anymore so
I've got teams of people I've got posted
on LinkedIn today about Sara L commit
buzz would these this new client would
filled three jobs yeah competitive brief
and she's just smashed out of the part
with and filled all three jobs so how
have you got better at dealing with the
fact that you're now paying more weight
is that how have you dealt with that
because that's obviously gonna that that
may prevent people from wanting to grow
their business like I'm just gonna make
sure you've got to be you've got you've
got to be on it you've just got to make
sure that you you're always just on top
of those things and again hiring people
who were good at that's so Jack again
coming in and helping us with the credit
control so we're making sure that you
know the money Barone's getting paid in
you know that invoices have been sent on
time all that just it's that consistency
of administration of the business
basically that's that's how you deal
with that mm-hmm because you know if you
if you look it's week before payday and
you're billed enough to pay those wages
then you need to start really worrying
about whether you did running your
business properly our problem has never
never been that it's only ever been the
fact that the credit controls out of
control that we're just getting booked
yeah she's getting paid that's if
anybody asks me before a setup what do
you think of it the toughest part being
owning a business and I thought it'd be
like getting it you know company to so
convinced you know sales directors have
big companies to use like an unknown
untested company but it's a hundred
percent getting paid is there a hardest
thing getting companies to pay you if
big companies are the worse one like 90
they pay the thing is it hasn't him as
an employee don't realise that you don't
know and it's educating them but again
we're quite open with it's really
everybody so
Jax jack oversees all but everybody to
chase their own death
really yeah how'd you said that sure
customer why wouldn't you that's really
interested in yeah they've done they owe
you money have you always done that yeah
I've always chased my own death why
would I let somebody else do it they
might bring up and we really are see
with them and like ruin my relationship
here so I can manage that so far if I
had a client owes me 10 grand you know
I'm gonna really dissipate you'd have
delivered for you I've done what you
asked me to do it's now hundred percent
less their money you know are you not
paying Commission if they are Commission
structure you paid ones to put the
invoices paid really yeah I mean come on
who runs the bar as if they don't pay
then I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure I
got Commission without the invoice being
paid yeah I mean I did it Hayes but
Hayes is like a billion quid that I was
they can afford they can afford that
yeah you I think you and I hide into
nothingness more company if you pay an
outcome again I think that's a good I
think it encourages people to have good
business commercial understanding of
their own it's not just it's not just a
done deal once do not mean I think
that's a good thing - there's so many
recruiters out there and recruitment
companies without uses like running your
own business managing your own desk and
then basically come in and the
micromanage the hell out of you and then
they and they take all that call the
actual business from you and do it all
in the background so you know if you
want to run your own desk that's part of
the processes you make a placement you
agree terms you agree payment terms you
invoice well I do what we send the
invoice successful Denis actually but
then you know you should know when that
invoice is due and you should be
speaking to your clients and basically
saying you know like that that payments
due next week are we okay for payment
and if it's late you know you know can
we get that paid because you know that's
that's on you actually you know it's
your is your business and we paid good
commissions so you know it's people want
to get paid that commission yeah and I
think I think that's fair it's just
interesting so that's definitely in the
biggest challenge chess game page it's
big companies as well all these ones
like you know you see all their adverts
and they're all about supporting little
companies
[Laughter]
that's a mighty there's yeah there must
have just so many people you have to
speak to the staff isn't that yeah and a
lot of these it's like their accounts
departments you know not in this country
that's just an email and nobody will
take a call yeah and it's just it's just
numb but we've got some great clients I
mean I'm not it's like a down customers
off but yes some of the some of them BMI
better chance we can work with anymore
basically yeah okay you done that deal
but when you getting paid I mean should
nobody should be embarrassed or ashamed
of being asked to be paid for the work
they've done yeah exactly
don't walk into Greg's and buy a
sandwich and then pay for it three weeks
later do you be using you know it's yeah
and nobody the girl behind the counter
all the blow behind the counters not
gonna go it year you know use not
embarrassed to take the money off you
it's just a transaction proud to be paid
for the way you've done what and so so
on this topic then so you had your best
year last year yeah do you know what I
was a bit more ruthless last year in
terms of like I fit because we split
fees so because we all work in the same
markets and we're all feeling pretty
much the same job we did with the
different customers we do a last bullet
fees so the fee is made of 50 percents
to candidate fifty cents a client you
own both habitat you you get the hundred
percent because I'm I'm better at the BD
side I'm better the client side I
generally get the job in fire it out so
everybody they some of the Seabees you
know people have interview people they
know Mike and it's great for this role
blah blah blah and they got half the
fares last yeah I feel a lot more of my
own job and I got I managed I work I
won't name the client but I managed to
take a client that I'd been working with
for three years as one of five on their
PSL and over that three years we send
them basically a breakdown that every
job their brief doubts waiting I filled
fulfilled every single job so it's like
just get rid of the other four do you do
your bar a is like to give it all to me
exclusive a yeah and I built I build
like literally half half of meetings
we've got one customer yeah so and to be
only say they're awesome as well so yeah
it's a great bit so yeah so what you're
talking about there is sort of focusing
on what your strengths are yeah
and then how it's interesting I think
it's come up a couple of times sort of
your experience or people's opinions on
the sort of 180 sort of model which is
war you're just talking about right
so if you
your businesses also yeah so Sarah
flexible if somebody's really good at
the full 360 you know crack on fill your
own jobs I've no issue with that but we
have a talent management team as well so
people whose job it is just to manage
our customer our candidates have you
found that impact really good really
good so that the sell internally is is
because the talent managers that that
fee is such their internal fee that they
just take a thousand pounds off the full
fee mmm and obviously they own
commission her placement rather than on
a fee value yeah so so as a consultant
you're much more likely to engage a
talent manager to help your resource a
role if you've got overfilled if you've
got too many roles and you're gonna fill
more roles if they're doing the
candidate work for ya but you only lose
a thousand pounds if you favor as if you
follow it so if I split the fee with you
yeah you could have to if as a consult
you gonna have to give me half the fee
aren't you so you're gonna lose half the
fee so there that's the way we did it to
get people to use the talent - plus it's
Ally manager's job isn't just to fill
jobs it's to manage our candidates build
relationships with them keep them
engaged sort some about you know what
they're looking for and and give the
candidates a better service not just
fire Seavey's our consultants basically
to fill jobs they're there they're there
that there are you know our
representatives to our when did you
start out so I think Daisy was the first
one think there's been in two years so
how do people you got in that team now
so it's just Daisy and Sarah at the
moment yeah so that's a Daisy looks
after the food food if the food and
non-food team so it looks after drinks
so all they do just to be clear as a
talent manager they it's the camera
experience Kath full kind of experience
so if I get a job on the new I mean we
head home we've a classical headhunting
not just yeah and in messages on
LinkedIn
so we'd said they do a lot of that they
do a lot market mapping okay so they're
constantly working for hours are sort of
our core customers so let's say I've got
a client isn't sorry yeah we will just
constantly be mining within 25 miles
yeah the other things yes their targets
are all about speaking to candidates
re-engaging candidates so if we've
registered money but not been in touch
for a while they've not been in touch
just getting back in touch with them we
do a LOF we
use HubSpot for a lot of panels in
reengagement funnels so those guys are
all over that yeah and working really
closely with marketing - yeah it's a
concern how and then how you structured
the Commissioner so I didn't understand
that so they get CSO a consultant gets
paid on Billings yeah where's the talent
managers because they don't have as much
control yeah it's all about the
placement but if so if you engage a
talent manager on your search so if you
say can you help me fill this job
whether their candidate fills it or not
or whether if somebody you found you've
got you've got it yeah you gotta pay
them so they get it it's an increasing
scale so one placements worth X amount
yeah - is worth at a bit more three four
or five so if they basically if they
make for placements um one thing could
they generally get about two grand I
think yeah they can only have four
placements pretty pretty that's the set
target so when you what's interesting
this and not everyone will use them
that's down to the consultant they do
totally I mean the cult chase there's no
hard and fast rules yeah it's all
cultural with us so it's all about
ownership and owning so the whole salon
is and they all bought into this is if
you uses somebody else to do resourcing
you can take on twice as many roles yeah
so you make twice as many placements and
it's work so how is that yeah how is
that actually impact if someone's
thinking you know what that actually
it's compliment from my office that
actually would actually be a really good
at a delivery side then maybe if they
were to focus on that that would
actually enable like how how is it
actually impacted getting more kind of
late it's filling modules oh it's huge
so what we've found recent with a couple
that included with a couple of other
changes that we've made
yeah all right we actually worked out
this [ __ ] we're making we're not getting
as many interviews okay but we're making
a lot more placements because really
let's see so much higher our ratios are
so much better and it's because the
Taliban who could spend more time with
the candidates so because that's all
they're focused on because that's all
they're focused on so when a teller
manager comes to you and says you need
to put this person in for this job let
me tell you why rather than you having a
half an hour on the phone call them on
an evening when you spoke to 20 other
candidates yeah and you you know you've
got your notes but they've spend you
know they've done a full video interview
with them they've got that in front of
them they can sell that to you you can
then sell that to your client so you
don't need as many interviews
in order to make the placement so from a
from a an internal piece it's miles
better but from a quality piece for our
customers is well the everybody wants to
end they don't want to interviewed that
nobody wants to any of you you know six
seven people it's three or four people's
great and it's well if you so if you can
if you can have confidence in your
recruiter that if he sends before people
I'm gonna hire yeah I mean we would just
over three three two one now for
everybody who's been here more than six
months so so what if okay this son this
sounds really interesting if I'm looking
at hiring someone to do this what do you
think there's sort of slight differences
you'd look for than a typical recruiter
you know I mean because I feel like the
type of person would be slightly
different yet actually I don't know if
there's any difference but they need to
need skills like in terms of
administration organization but they
need to be engaged like have you found
really passionate people and really
really good listeners and I know
recruiters need to be good listen yeah
but what they're trying to do is is
differentiate good from great with
candidates where as a recruiter a lot of
the time you're just trying to fill a
job because you're up against ten others
whereas they can take a lot more time
but also what you've else you've got to
be able to manage really well is the
fact that you can't influence the
process as much once you pass that CV to
your consultant and they put it forward
so as a recruit so you send the Seabees
you can chase the client you can you
know you can influence you can sell that
candidate and again the tala managers
can't do that so they've got to have
confidence in their team yeah so that
you've got to be able to manage that
within your not big like kicking
everybody's ass every five minutes yeah
you know and be understanding as like
some clients take longer to come back
and and that's everything so yes so
there's a bit of that but I think the
communication is key there yeah but also
just yeah I've been but just been so
much more good because like as I say a
lot of its reagent and it's not just
about finding candidates for jobs it's
about managing that database of
candidates and keeping them engaged in
giving them a good experience with us
because we did mud into feedback loops
so making sure that those that feedback
is is
as good as it can be you've got to be
really quality focused so it's not just
a volume game yeah but we found how
recruiters out like I either but I'm
just trying to solve differentiate from
other recruiters I mean I've I were to
haze for a long time and that was all
based on how many Seabees I'm gonna send
out so many but that was that's had a
big impact on your business it's tunes
like yeah really I mean that quality's
just through the roof compared so it's
compared to what it was yeah totally
breeze and I think that's the way we
want to go we you know we're very very
niche in what we do yeah every every
consultant recruits pretty much one role
yeah so you know National Account
Managers or technical managers or supply
chain managers they all focus on that
yeah I'm all about specificity yeah I
think I think it's why is that so
important in today's today's what I
think because because you've got so many
online tools and still I've got to build
networks and if you build a network if I
try to build a generalist network my
message will get lost in it and it and
it doesn't resonate with enough people
whether I'm ID pedometer crew National
Accounts hmm so though the content I'm
creating and all the messages aren't
creating to those people it's yet
directed directly out them and it
hopefully it'll impact them and they'll
relate to it so the more likely to
engage with me whereas if I was
recruiting supply chain managers and
technical managers and marketeers and
everything a mess to get lost
yeah this just I've got to be so much
more generic with my messaging yeah
because I like to sort of focus in I
mean I do wish yeah I mean I believe
massively in social media I'm um yeah
you know post a lot and I get good
engagement and I and I believe it's the
way forward and I think we're we've
embraced that but I think of nation is
employment like their knees she's super
important it's like you want to build a
network and you want to be the go-to guy
so if a sales director rings me up I can
generally guarantee my love of shortlist
women's forty hours if it's if it's a
National Account Manager yeah in the UK
you know in one of the major population
hubs which of Germany's or home-based
role I will get you five series you want
to interview within 48 hours
hmm do you know because we know the
market so well we know the candidates we
know who's good and weak because we only
recruit that role and we've been doing
it for so long you know you know the
difference between good and great so I
know what good looks like I know what
great looks like
I know what they do I get them into
training the stuff on what is their job
is to do so I think it's that that
expertise and that's what people want
hmm so over the last sort of 18 24
months may you grow in the business
quite a lot how important is it being
for you to sort of build that layer
beneath you like the cause obviously
yeah the people that I've been with
today Future Leaders obviously you got
another chap that it's been review
longer who new user more of a leader
underneath you yeah it's like just
pretty much now you've got me and Sam
yeah I learned the company and then
within our leadership team there's me
Sam Aidan and dancer Aidan's
had super drinks team Aidan was i sat
down and ate him and this isn't they're
not in these positions because of this
but they're for our first number one a
number to impress yeah Dan was our first
ever hire he heads of marketing and then
Aidan came in and they've both just
smashed it so and they're both bought in
they're on the journey yeah they will
they will become full directors
hopefully next financial year yeah and
so they'll be put on the board
officially yeah and we're just going
through all those how important has it
been to get that have those people
massive like that get that like concrete
that their leaders they're bought into
light well they're both very good at
what they do so we I do think we'd keep
them really as much as we'd like to
consider them good friends before they'd
do their own thing well they're
ambitious guys if I can't create create
an opportunity for them I'll be like you
need to leave yeah you know I can't
deliver what you need and you're better
than the job you're in now so I've got
to keep creating opportunities to keep
them here and that's that's the way I
see cuz you know they're really for them
aren't they they're not in it for me
their life and when the purpose of their
life isn't a facility may you start
really cultivating that but I have
always been it's at least it's for me
was it's always been you've got to
create those layers because that's how
you keep people because your tree
opportunities for them yeah and we can't
create opportunities for people without
that layer of management yeah I can't
grow the business because there's only
so many people I can manage directly and
some can manage and Aidan can manage so
we need to put this tier of this
managers in now so we've got five people
who are on the Future Leaders program
and that their job is over this year is
to take as much training as we can we
can afford to give them
load sell for them show us that they're
ready mmm
lead from the front you know be
ambassadors for our culture and ass and
as soon as we can
well we'll put people yea put people
underneath them in a couple of them
already got I've already got reports and
we're building that structure in what
we're not gonna do is typical recruit oh
you had a good year there's four staff
yeah go manage them and still build me
two hundred and fifty grand a year
because it's it's just a you just on a
road to failure there so it's for me
it's about doing it properly you're
making sure that they they can deliver
in their marketplace and and add that
extra how did you identify those people
if I'm listening right now and like how
office Lee you've got a judge these
people about how how have you how did
you identify those people to invest in I
did him all individually said they've
all got different skills Seban for
example yeah he's just he's a great
coach he's great mentors alright
listener he's he's got time for
everybody so I thinking from that point
of view
he's just an ears and natural manager
yeah he's developing areas to be a bit
more ruthless yeah and he knows Suffolk
yeah who sees the CC he's one of those
people who's just genuinely just
genuinely lovely Sarah's just a
workhorse nothing's ever too much she's
so organized she's on it she's bright
she's just she's just like the perfect
employee so I'm I need to Sarah needs
that opportunity in order to say you
know hold her hold her up and like
that's how you should be doing I don't
know if I give her the opportunity to to
manage people she'll up to this mush out
of the park so everybody's got their
individual yeah yeah and to be honest
with you I could have put eight people
really I don't think there's anybody in
the business that I don't look and think
you're young leader team or you know you
won't be here next year anything like
that so how important was it to species
people about what this could mean long
term like besides management and stuff
are you talking some about yeah what
what I looks like for them in terms of
being part of the business long term
five ten years like that's I don't know
is that important to speak to people
like that I think for them is imagine if
somebody came to you and they were like
Rob we're gonna put you through this
program yeah because we really believe
in you and we think you know you know
you're gonna be a really important part
of this business and everybody knows
what our goals are now swell
we want to be how big we want to be and
obviously they know what structure we've
got the structure planned out in terms
of sort of what that's going to look
like so they know that that from where
they are now if everybody achieves what
they need to achieve in five years time
what their role will look like and what
their earning potential will be what
they're you know what this when you do
their role it's always been what always
updating it those feeding it back and
interview us we we get a lot of input
from those guys really say yes what do
you want to do where do you see yourself
going yeah yeah that's also not
adjusting from the small business right
now how many yeah I think if you haven't
got sort of those people in your
business or copper vein that you need to
don't you I think what a lot of people
do is they they try to be like a big
company before they are a big company so
they try to have all these sort of
layers of management and like this
hierarchy of like you know I only talked
to the person below me and then they
talk to plus I think when you want a
small business you just gotta throw all
the how the window yeah because at the
end of the day I'm just that opposite
the most junior person in the company no
you know like I'm not gonna talk to them
and now do you know that was important
to me as anybody else were you know I
want to share what we're doing with them
yeah you know there's no need to have
like layers of hierarchy and layers of
ego and all that sort of stuff like you
know I'm more important than you at the
end of the day well that's what
everybody's still you know all the
pillars we all still build money we've
got we've all got the same free target
there's no sort of different fee targets
of different levels everyone's got to
make the same amount of money we're
gonna make the same our placements
everybody knows what everybody else is
doing it's all transparent so there's no
need for anybody to have ego so some
people have got different roles within
within that family really so going for
it over to the last 18 24 months would
you do anything differently do you think
little things go on I'm just yeah I'm
sure I think no not actually probably
want to spend as much money in a b3 as
we did yeah I got about of and on the
money we were to the Ocean Beach Club
and that was so expensive like the
biggest biggest amount of money I've
ever spent
really yeah but they've deserved it I
mean we smashed it last year in terms of
sort of fees fees generated so yes it
was it was it was well
deserved but it's still either I'm a
counselor snake you know spending sort
of thousands on on drinks and stuff it
just hurts me I'm a Yorkshire but an you
did different anything that you think
could have other night oh yeah
anything that you think could have had a
maybe you wish you did it earlier or I
don't know anything that's coming up for
you
no I think I think I don't have regrets
as such and I think I think there's
there's things that we might change yeah
and sort of aspects of the business that
we might change and different directions
we might go in but ya know I'm damp you
know delayed was where we are and you
know thank my lucky stars every day that
I'm in this position so yeah I don't
think there's I wouldn't there's nothing
I would change apart from one hire yeah
we were talked about him oh yeah it was
he was just wrong on every level here
and I thought I could I thought I could
make something decent out of him and I
was was just wrong yeah it was just the
wrong he's probably my only regret
railing how is this journey had been for
you personally mate what's that been
like that been tough yes pretty pretty
mental actually so I literally my
bothers him Bob look my daughter Marty
her she's pretty much like was born yeah
I'd just be like just after we set the
company up so it's like that's why you
know that was my motivation to do it so
that was a struggle was there a factor
of light if you don't it now when you're
gonna do you've got no option I had to
deliver
so then what the where I was at as an
employee of a company yeah from what I
wanted to deliver for my family
on a personal level not like needed to
but just wanted to you know create for
my family just wasn't gonna be was never
gonna be it I was never gonna be able to
do that and that's not just financial
but that's in terms of like I dropped my
daughter at school every morning you
know if I want to go hang out with her
I'll just literally just say right I'm
off see you later I'm leaving a three or
whatever it might be and I go get from
nursery so I get spend loads of time
with her and she's just that's just
awesome so that's really really good
really hard the first two years she just
didn't sleep so I didn't sleep for two
years that would that was hard when he's
setting a company up and yeah so I
literally lived on on Red Bull for like
two years
yeah he was tough but it's worth it you
know it's worth it we said that what
that was that was difficult but other
than that it sounds really big anybody's
fairly straightforward
you know the how do you think that is
over compare yeah Ricki which I keep is
simple focus on our customers deliver
for them stick to what you know don't
try to be everything to all men don't
sort of try you know fill every job go
in you know focus on the jobs you can
fill yeah yeah just do good do well few
customers and just don't don't be don't
over egg what you what you're capable of
doing and be satisfied with what you can
achieve rather than you know I want to
be a 10 million pound company when
you're turning over 300 grand you know
it's like well what's the next step so
we're 300 run now how do we get to five
you know we're at just over like a
million off now so our next goal is how
do we get two and a half and how do we
maintain the profit a reasonable level
that we can then get to five you don't
stall that sort of thing so you know
it's that's that's what it's all about
for me it's just continuing it I don't
think we'll ever sell the company not in
it for like a five-year accent that
makes you that helps you make better
decisions like like the decision to
invest loads of money back into the
busier we got no debt don't think we'll
ever Bora money I'd rather than would
just take a bit longer and I know that's
like that with people are they when are
you need to scale your business won't
anybody be able to tell us how to do it
we've nothing and what's clear Matt is
you're something you enjoy you enjoy
what you're doing yeah that's the most
important thing right I think scale more
people who ever like are you enjoying
more you build then yeah if you ever get
to the point where it's like all right
I would I would if it got to like a
hundred people I'd be pretty cool I
think now but I might you might might I
might hate it yeah and at that point I
probably would sell and just start again
yeah it's like 10 15 yeah yeah I just I
love recruitment I love the job I see
myself as a recruiter I don't see myself
as an MD or yeah or anything like I am a
recruiter first and foremost
and I just do what I have another job
that you know he's to basically help
everybody else do we do what they need
to do I'm sure they'll come a time where
we might be a bit bigger and I've like
literally reached my
my level and I'm after bring in somebody
to tell me what to do every day run the
business quick one night before we
finish so just on that point I think
just real practical advice just because
you've been through it if I'm the
business owner right now and I'm
thinking about just that scaling scaling
period of year ten fifteen ten to twenty
heads or whatever like you've gone free
and I know that's going to hit the
profit it's like what what sort of what
we expected what should I expect
realistically that in terms of what
could hit how could that impact my
profit like what sort of percentage
we're talking that impacted your
business yeah I'd say so our profit
percentage but about ten percent down
yeah yeah yeah work towards experiencing
or having ten to fifteen with all those
hires yeah only starting to shift now
because those guys are now starting to
better understand that they're starting
to be profitable rather than if you had
a great if you had a really good year
like Rio and and really put put a lot of
this back into the business gonna
involve hiring blah blah blah
yeah plant you at least ten to twenty
percent yeah for at least six months
yeah but also don't don't panic and fire
the people you've hired because they're
not making you enough money and yeah you
know you've got you've got this profit
number and yet I've got to make fifty
percent margin you know net net margin
or whatever it might be whatever that
number is in your head they says even
though as long as you've got goal in
mind in terms of sort of where you want
to beef you know from in the long term
you know focus on that goal rather than
on month by month oh you know what last
month we made deer fifty six percent
margin and this year we've made forty
two and it's this month we move forward
to the compared to last year does it
really matter does it does it really
matter you you are not Procter & Gamble
you know you've not got you know you're
not on the footsie 100 you've not got
shareholders it's not gonna affect your
share price and if unless you're
planning to say it's like your house if
y'all's goes down in value it only
matters if you want to sell it yeah do
you know what I mean it's about so if
it's invest in any company and your
people and hiring the right people and
then backing them to deliver and yeah
and expect ik and accepting that that
might cost you a bit of money over no I
think that's very good advice it's like
no way you want to be with that
investment and what you're putting in
over the next 3-5 years
and yeah when you do notice that there's
a bit of a hit like that's not hitting
you hard and you're not just focusing on
the short terms you know I mean it's
gonna help you see it through right you
know who's ever hired anybody do you
hear stories don't you like consultants
come in first year they bail quarter of
a million and yeah I how I've done that
well you know your first year if you
make fifty percent of your annual target
you're laughing if you've got no
experience and recruitment I expect that
they're gonna make fifty percent at the
profit that you want them to make ya
really gonna build some of them I shared
an episode of a guy called Tom is it a
property recruiter and he he did 200 and
that's all this one yeah maybe like 215
in the first year right but he's like
he's like he's like nearly like six
years in now his best years yeah crazy
your best year I've guided 94 grand in
my first year Ellis Fairbank anybody
holdable Romero's Burbank so look one or
two questions before we finish make
final questions have an event coming up
with the podcast all about resilience
what is resilience and recruitment mean
to you may i'd always got it bounce back
ability bounce back ability yeah and
that's just an old term I was taught
when I first started out it's almost
like you've almost no gotten not got to
care mmm it's like you do obviously you
care yeah but you've almost got to be in
a position where you know you know it's
something's gonna go wrong
yeah who's ever had to recruit all the
recruiter listen Isis has anybody ever
gone from you know job in to fill with
no hurdles yeah it no it just doesn't
happen there's always something
something in the contract so you know
yeah they can't make the interviews and
you've got big gaps is always something
and to think I tried to explain to
everybody else is if you don't really
give a lot one job on or one chance to
make a fee that month and it doesn't
come in you shouldn't be surprised you
know give yourself the Ritz really easy
to build resilience if you've got ten
ten things of final interview and you
know video I've them you're laughing
someone's you might
ten you know see in terms of sort of
building that resilience it's like
you've just got to expect the worst back
there and you've got to remember we're
dealing with psyche so much out of our
control
yeah you know we can't we can't make
people hire people they can't make
people say jobs and we should never try
because that's not what people are
paying what can people do to sort of
start instilling that in their team's
anything that you do I I don't think you
can make somebody resilient nah I said
but what I think you can do is help them
reduce the amount of resilience they
need by yeah having more in their
pipeline so if they're if you've got who
everybody knows that recruit was only
ever got one candidate for a job you
know there's one candidate wonder so
they've got ten job he's the ones that
I'll got tents and outs this week and
it's like yes a ten job so they've got
one candidate in every job it's like
there's a really good luck that they
won't make any fees that month they
won't make any place was so first of all
that giving us customers a crop services
like the literally one candidate wonder
but they just always set themselves up
for failure so it's like that person
their focus should always be half the
number of jobs you working can put more
more good people into the jobs focus
more on game more quality into less jobs
yeah you know until you're able to fill
ten jobs with three great candidates or
five great cameras in each one so then
you don't need to be as really don't
need to deal with disappointment as much
I think I think it's natural isn't it
yeah anything that you're excited about
mate obviously going into the new
financial year very soon but anything
you wanna shout about what yes I think
the biggest thing for me is grocery aid
this at the moment so I was really
really chuffed last year they asked me
to tips off joined the northern northern
branches committee
so I've buried myself in now and I'm
currently like tasked with arranging our
our annual golf days which raises money
for the charity where we are big big
back this year is is barcode Festival
which is the grocery industry is run by
groceries a big festival one-day
festival loads of the big suppliers
Heinekens and and people like that come
and do massive activations the whole
industry goes about four thousand people
going this year we support this leaf
there's in London down near the docks
talk house was last year okay but
they've moved it to a bigger venue this
year
involved with that so yes we we we
support gross red by basically doing all
their social media for them yeah it's
not free of charge
so we do all that for them so we shift a
lot tickets for them but we we've
sponsored the event this year and got
ourselves a big big ten area so we're
gonna take use that as our big client
client day so we've got 50 tickets
exciting so if there any FMCG sales
directors listening yeah and I think
it's a barcode it was a baker's I am yes
so that's our big bet this our big
marketing bet so that's that's really
important to me but this Future Leaders
thing I'm just really excited about what
where they're gonna be that's in it in
like six months time we've got some
great so obviously you're supporting us
on that I've got we had mr. Benjamin
Dennehy days most hate sales training we
took it seems to see him recently that
was amazing I've never come out a
training course like knowing that I'm a
lot [ __ ] than I thought it was before
when I was like yeah I'm a good salesman
oh it's Sal I've been on that yeah yeah
I just ripped me to pieces
so yeah and then we've got loads of sort
of leadership training and everything
else so yes I'm really yeah and I've
just got loads I just yeah and I'm just
like what they're getting out of it like
everybody seen buzzing today when they
come out of there and was with their
after the session with you so that's I
think it's just I think that's gonna be
really the next step for me is more how
can I turn consultants into leaders and
give them opportunities and you know
down the line open OHS if they want
their own businesses we might be able to
help them out with ours well we may find
a question tom could communicate to
every single recruiter out there
business owner phrase words what would
you say to these people mate if they'd
listen and take on an advice just focus
on your customer mmm deliver its deliver
for your customers stop worrying about
how much money you're making
yeah just focus on filling jobs with
great candidates and you literally have
nothing else to worry about
it's a sin if is the simplest job in the
world
Tom it's been a pleasure man yeah I've
enjoyed it cheers me